code review the series where you guys
send me your amazing projects and I
roast and I take a look at them quick
reminder if you have a cool project that
you want me to take a look at and give
some feedback on channel review
gmail.com is where you can send in all
of your stuff there are some details in
the description of this video today
we're taking a look at grass rendering
in opengl slash cable Plus for code
review series by some pineapple hey on
my name is Nathan I'm 15 years old and
I've made a scene in opengl with a lot
of grass I was inspired to make this
project after seeing a YouTube video
from Ace roller titled modern foliage
rendering I have seen that video I
believe so I think I know what he's
talking about though many of the
techniques I use are different than what
he did feedback I'm looking for
optimizations I think oh here's a nice
little screenshot that's cool okay
that does look like a lot for us
optimizations I think is running pretty
fast already but I'm sure there is room
for improvement and also code structure
slash memory management I learned C plus
plus mostly off of YouTube and it was
after writing Java for a couple years it
wasn't until about six months ago I
learned that all my previous code had
been full of memory leaks because I used
a new keyword everywhere without
cleaning things up Okay cool so we've
got a 15 year old who has mostly learned
table Plus off YouTube and there may be
some optimizations but also code
structure memory management is what they
want us to take a look at thanks so much
for reading my email best Nathan I
develop on Linux but all it depends
these included get sub modules so it
should Compound on Windows as long as
you clone with the recursive flag cool
let's get this running it's running I
don't know why I keep clapping so here
we have opengl grass FPS is not bad
there's quite a lot of grass here I have
no idea how many
Blades of grass we're rendering here it
looks like I can move around with wst
keys I can't seem to move around with
the
Mouse at all like there's no rotation
which is a little bit underwhelming I
would have loved to have seen some
rotation because I can't even really
inspect the grass and I can't get lower
either it's just wasd I think also this
window is like what is this like a
one-to-one aspect ratio and also not
resizable like what is going on here but
hey like it works it's pretty cool I can
just is this like going to be like an
infinite kind of environment I can just
keep going forward and maybe the chunks
will like replace themselves with where
they are definitely pretty cool though
you can see that there's like some
subtle movement as well
each of these Blades of grass are kind
of moving I would like to have seen a
little bit more variation with the color
and also it does look like there is some
darkening as it gets lower but perhaps
just not quite enough darkening to kind
of simulate that ambient occlusion I
could talk a lot about grass rendering
by the way but I'm going to try and
restrain myself here yeah I think we
might we might we might jump in and play
with some of the colors at some point
today just to try and make this look a
little bit more realistic perhaps I've
uh spent some time outside today
looked at some grass so
I have pretty good idea of what it looks
like and this is not bad but I think we
could improve it all right let's dive
into the code oh look to find winter
width window height in the main.cpp file
so let's just what happens if we make
this like a little bit bigger is this
gonna fall apart yes it is okay so now
you can actually kind of see the edges
oh and if I move you can see the edges
of these chunks
right so it's offloading the chunks that
get out of like the camera's frosting
but unfortunately what's happened is I
think that that kind of square that we
saw in the beginning that was basically
like the camera's frosting it still
thinks the camera size or whatever like
the The View that the camera can see is
still confined into this area which is
why for example like this chunk gets
unloaded this one might remain just
because it might look like this or
something there might be part of it
intersecting that camera frosting but
it's cool to kind of see I guess this
like uh Frost and culling you know chunk
culling uh you know system I guess
working when we make the uh the field of
view of the camera wider by just making
the aspect ratio wider because that's
basically what we did the FPS no it
hasn't actually Fallen it's like exactly
the same as what it was when we were
looking at it at a thousand by a
thousand which we've basically doubled
the amount of pixels we went from
something that was a thousand by a
thousand to now 1920x1080 which is about
2 million pixels versus 1 and so we've
doubled the number of pixels the
resolution is twice as high however the
FPS stays the same and that of course is
because there's not there's not much
fragment like shading going on here the
pixel Shader is probably quite light
it's really just the uh the number of
like triangles that we're rendering here
that we're pushing through is probably
very high
I'm interested to dive into the code and
take a look at how this is drawn I'm
pretty sure these are just going to be
these do look like individual pieces of
geometry that have just been instanced
like a bajillion times which is uh
pretty pretty like standard fairly
decently performant way to go and then
I'm going to take a guess that this kind
of swaying that's happening here that
also seems to be based on the height of
the vertex that makes up a grass blade
so if we have this kind of grass blade
over here that looks like that
uh the higher we go the more we move it
and then the lower we are the less we
move because the base shouldn't move
obviously we don't want our grass going
like this but we do want it kind of
swaying like that and that's probably
just uh animated using actually it does
look like each yeah each individual
grass blade does look to be on on a
different path like maybe the movement's
the same but it's on a different stage
of its animation which makes me think
there's probably some kind of
position based attribute there as well
that maybe will tie into like some kind
of sine wave or like some kind of like
sine or cosine function basically that
will just oscillate it back and forth
but at different kind of stages of that
graph and that kind of makes them all
look independent which I don't know like
I have mixed feelings about that because
obviously like whilst grass maybe does
move slightly differently like each
individual blade of grass will move
maybe a little bit differently compared
to like the ones next to it overall the
wind blowing on it is going to be like
the same right so like this chunk of
grass blades is going to have the same
wind Force coming on it there might be
other factors like certain blades might
block the wind from other blades I guess
but overall they should more or less
have the same effect or at least be in
larger chunks so there are some things
as I said I could talk about grass for a
very long time but yeah those are kind
of my thoughts in general though pretty
cool system I like the fog as well the
fog looks pretty nice there's a lot that
kind of Fade Out
um that we see here I don't know if
that's going to be based on the actual
distance ends of the grass from the
camera or just like is it like I said if
that's calculated using like say a depth
buffer or if that's actually just like
the literal position compared to the
camera because if grass is the only
thing you're rendering which of course
is the case here then you can just kind
of hack it you don't really need to you
know make it work with other 3D objects
or anything like that now if you're new
to programming and you want to develop
your computer science skills a little
bit further as well as learn some math
and I highly recommend you check out
brilliant the sponsor of today's video
brilliant is an amazing website filled
with lots of courses on various stem
topics it is by far the best place to
learn all of this because of how
interactive and engaging it is hands-on
experience is the best way to learn
anything and Brilliant gives you that
experience by not just teaching you and
throwing information at you but also
getting you to engage with the content
quizzing you about what they're teaching
you and showing you how things work
visually now I'm a fairly experienced
program I've been around the block a few
however
math is something that I constantly want
to revise I've been going through
Brilliance calculus courses to revise
and make sure I know everything I need
to for the ray tracing series which by
the way did I mention that because their
lessons are nicely organized you can
just spend like 15 30 minutes a day
going through all this stuff you don't
have to commit hours if you only have a
spare moment you could just do a lesson
or two and that kind of consistency is
really important if you can just spend a
little bit of time learning each and
every day you'll get very far and if
calculus is a little bit too advanced
for you want to kind of start at the
beginning then brilliant have this brand
new everyday math course that will put
you on the right Journey the best thing
is that you can get started with
brilliant for free just go to
brilliant.org the channel link will be
in the description however the first 200
people who sign up using my link in
description below will get 20 off an
annual membership so definitely hurry
and do that it's a great way to commit
to being consistent in your learning
huge thank you brilliant for sponsoring
this video alright so since code
structure was one of the things we
should be reviewing doing let's just
take a take a quick look at this so we
have a main function and we have like
most of our application over here I
would definitely abstract this a little
bit the reason being that this will just
continue growing in kind of a more real
application the complexity of this
section of the code is just going to
explode for something as simple as just
a little grass test though it's hard to
kind of give advice sometimes because if
this is the entirety of the application
you know can I really say that oh yeah
it's going to grow it's going to explode
it's going to get so much bigger it's
like 90 lines of code this might be the
whole program so why complicate things
and over abstract things that's a really
that's that's a good point it really
does make it difficult to kind of code
review certain applications because I'm
not sure if this person wants me to kind
of assume that this is like just how
they would write a program and guide
them into the right direction for
writing larger applications which they
might potentially do in the future or if
I should look at this product as a whole
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below because honestly like
this is one of the things that gets me
every time ignoring that though we
initialize jlfw we set some up in jail
contact stuff we create the window over
here I don't really like this uh
asterisk for the GLW window pointer
being like in the middle I think that's
a bit weird I know some people do that
but I think that's a bit weird I
personally like writing it next to the
type however some people like writing it
next to the variable that's fine you do
you but uh don't leave it in the middle
who's middle gang like if you guys are
middle gang let me know but that's just
that's just weird all right LW swap
interval zero which is going to disable
vsync we create the open shell context
here and tie it to this thread and that
window and then we're using glue but
like gl3w to just get some opengl
extensions going and then we have our
Shader our mesh our grass renderer and
our camera fairly neat I like the fact
obviously that these are not Heap
allocated like you mentioned they might
have been it's very common for people
coming from Java or c-sharp to just make
objects like this and in C plus because
they consider that to be the equivalent
which in a lot of ways it is because
pretty much everything is Heap allocated
in Java and in C sharp like you have
structs which are not Heap allocated
however classes obviously are and since
Shader is a class it kind of this really
is like the equivalent however C sharp
and Java they have garbage collectors
which means of course that your memory
will just be cleaned up automatically
after it hasn't been used for a while in
C plus plus that of course is not the
case if we create this like this using
the new keyword and is created on the
Heap we'll have to delete it somewhere
but that's not the only consideration
there's also a performance consideration
because if we're making things on the
Heap we have to find a free chunk of
memory which will slow down the
allocation process but then also that
memory is likely going to be somewhere
else inside our RAM and if we're dealing
with like fragmented memory that can
slow down our program every time we need
to read and write to or from that memory
so those are basically the reasons for
why you don't want to like Heap allocate
this using the new and delete keyword
but instead you just want to use the
stack as much as possible the stack will
always be hot inside our memory inside
our CPU cache because well we we're
reading from the stack constantly and
writing to it constantly as we progress
through this actual function so of
course that's going to be okay all right
so yeah we load this Shader I'm assuming
we just basically load it using opengl
yep we just load the actual Shader text
and compile it which looks pretty good
we're even deleting it at the end here
which is which is good because we want
to delete the individual like Shader
intermediates basically and we link this
all into into our program which of
course we don't delete until we get to
the destructor which uh yeah doesn't
exist here so we're actually not freeing
that program what you should do is
create a Destructor here for your Shader
class and then have that actually called
jail delete program so that you can
actually get rid of your Shader program
speaking of which one thing I would do
which you don't have to do I know some
people don't like to and that's okay is
uh use some kind of convention for your
naming like for variables right so what
I would do is instead of just having
this written as Trader program ID I
would rename it to M underscore Shader
id M here stands for member because it's
kind of like a member variable that's
private I do this for my private like
non-static member variables the reason
why I do that is because it can be a
little bit confusing when you look
through this code to just see this and
be like okay is this something that
belongs to the class like is it a member
variable or is it a local variable of
course there are things like syntax
highlighting in fact you can see that
these are a slightly different color
from this and the reason that's
happening is because I have a slightly
different color for my local variables
than my like member variables however
that's just something I'm used to and
again I did say that it's okay to
disagree and you can do whatever you
want but I like doing that because in my
experience I've just found in larger
projects especially when it happens to
matter more if potentially if stuff is
like a member variable or a local
variable this can really help kind of
readability at a glance just to see like
okay what's going on here okay I can
kind of piece this together the other
thing you should do is well the other
thing I would do is initialize is my
variables so Shader program ID here is
not assigned to anything and you're also
not assigning it here so there are two
ways to initialize this variable you can
either just write equals zero over here
inside the header file which is what I
would do or you can alternatively use
this little colon over here which looks
a bit weird and then just set a value
like this right I mean you could also
set a value like that that's totally
fine but this will kind of initialize it
before it gets into this code
why would you do something like this if
you set it over here anyway well first
of all functions like this can fail
right like for example you may not have
loaded that function and so it might
fail right or something could happen
here like you could get a crash
somewhere here and if you get a crash
somewhere here and you're debugging and
you take a look at this Trader program
ID and it's some random value that can
really throw you off or alternatively if
something like an exception happened
inside one of these functions it didn't
execute the rest of this function or
whatever you have a Shader with a Shader
program ID of xero so you can tell that
this has not been created right you
could also kind of set it back to zero
like a pointer once you've deleted it
here however I wouldn't really do this
in the destructor because that object's
going to die anyway but my point here is
just that like in my experience I found
that it's really really really useful to
have variables properly initialized
because when you are debugging something
it just helps tremendously to be able to
see what state your kind of objects and
variables are in and if it's just random
uninitialized memory then well yeah good
luck it makes stuff a lot harder
there's that uh Middle Point again
um so we get uniform location by uh cons
Char pointer which is okay opengl
function is taking a const chart pointer
personally I wouldn't I would take in
either a string view or there's my
little string view or I would take in
like a const STD string however again
the opengl API does take in construct
pointers so I'm not going to fault you
too much for that look at my failing of
typing up string view there uh you
should probably also pass large objects
by reference instead of by value so a
map 4 is 64 bytes because it's got 16
floats inside it so I would change this
to be a const reference because that
will avoid copying that memory fun fact
uh we were working on something back in
the day at EA on the mobile engine and
we found that we had like a function
that passed in a bunch of these mat4s
basically not like glm matt4s but our
own math types but they were 64 bytes
and we found that the program would
perform faster if for one of them I
think it was the last parameter if we
made that be by value and this to be by
reference unlike some Android
um device probably so anyway moral of
the story is uh my general advice is yes
that's 64 bytes of data let's cop let's
not copy it let's just const reference
it however
yeah from my story you can see that
sometimes that's not that's not
necessarily correct let me just restore
this as well and then we'll be back to
normal and especially because like
there's no reason for this to contain a
copy of course of this data because at
the end of the day all we're doing is
obtaining like a pointer to that that
memory buffer and passing it opengl
anyway speaking of which you have a
false here however this takes in a GL
Boolean this is something that probably
isn't a big deal in practice but because
of GL bullying if we take a look at a
jail Boolean you'll see that it's
actually an unsigned char
right so it's like a one byte kind of
integer type it's not an actual Boolean
I mean booleans don't might not really
exist anyway but they do in C plus plus
technically so because of that what I
would do is I would use gel false here
instead of false again realistically
you're probably not going to see any
difference false is usually going to map
to zero however that does make me feel a
little bit uneasy so I would just use
the correct kind of term here and gel
false as you can see is just defined to
just be zero which of course is the
right type for an unsigned Char which is
what that gel Boolean is that's the kind
of main point here the underlying type
is an unsigned Char therefore I would
feel better providing it with an actual
unsigned Char getting back over here
into the main class we have a mesh class
so mesh and floor mat I I said main
classes are just a main function though
so forgive me mesh floor mesh and then
we load this assetsplain.obj and
probably could just generate like a a
plane instead of having to load it in
for from like an obj but that's okay
you've got an explicit mesh Constructor
here okay and then that takes in a cons
Char path so again you're taking in a
construct path now realistically this is
a cons Char right so sometimes when I'm
kind of talking about C plus plus uh you
know it's very common to kind of want to
use strings potentially and so people
end up like over using I guess strings
but then there's also the flip argument
where if you actually Define like a
string literal like this and you look at
it it's just a cons Char array because
this actual string is going to be like
compiled into like a reader in the
memory section of your binary that is
going to be this resulting program it's
physically going to be there inside like
the binary data and this is a pointer to
that like read-only block of memory if
this did take in like an STD string
then it's a little bit annoying in a way
because what would happen is this const
chart pointer would have to be used to
construct an actual string instance so
string will have a Constructor that
takes in a construct pointer and now
we're actually making an object
implicitly by just passing in like an
actual string that we've hard-coded into
our c plus code and that can be bad like
strings can dynamically allocate memory
that could result in a heap allocation
there is something called small string
optimization if your string is small
enough it will just store it on the
stack within this string object which
will be faster but even faster than that
it will just be to use a cons Char
pointer and that's why like in a lot of
cases I do like using string view
because string view at its core it's
just a pointer to like a just a a
character array and then also like a
size associated with that array and so
in other words it doesn't store anything
it can point to either an actual string
and its allocated memory in a kind of a
non-owning way so it's not going to like
copy it or delete it or anything like
that or it can point to a cons Char uh
to a cons Char pointer and that can be
used for your kind of compile time
strengths so I would really recommend
that you take a look at string view
because it's just a it's a great little
utility class in the past in larger
projects that I've worked on uh we had
like back at EA we had like our own like
uh strain class I think it was called
like symbol or something like that and
basically what symbol would be is that
would represent something that would
actually be like a compile time constant
string versus like you know I think we
had like our own string class which
would represent like a dynamically
allocated string so strings like string
semantics and everything like there's a
lot to talk about there almost as much
as I could talk about grass for all
right speaking of which I didn't
actually take a look at the mesh class
but uh we read in that uh obj and
because it's an obj obj is for those of
you who don't know a very very simple
format let me see if I can bring one up
so here we have our plain obj you can
see over here that it's been created
with blender 3.1.2 we have a little
material Library there's an external
file file that's pointing to here we
have an object called plane and then
this is all of the vertex data for it
but it's not actually all of the vertex
data it's specifically the vertex
positions so they're marked with v even
though they're not the whole vertex
they're just a position and they're
listed over here and then if we scroll
this is a very very uh like tessellated
plane look how many vertices 56 000
vertices for a plane okay that's
interesting I don't know why it's so
dense uh maybe he's using the vertices
for something right so if you're using
the vertices for something maybe you
want them there to be like a lot of them
in place kind of at certain areas I'm
not sure maybe maybe they're even being
used to spawn the grass although I don't
think so because it looked pretty like
evenly distributed all right then we
have VT which is like the UV coordinate
of each vertex this is like yeah this is
263 000 lines then we have these faces
which are basically uh indices that make
up a triangle so this index like the
vertex at this index the vertex of this
index and the vertex this index creates
uh one triangle and then we have three
of these actually no sorry I'm wrong
this is the vertex position this is the
texture coordinate and then this is
probably like the normal or something so
this is like the vertex position the
texture coordinate and the normal and
this is one vertex one vertex one vertex
three of them make a triangle thus
making a face and that is our little obj
format so we read them in using util's
load obj which will basically parse all
of this text another reason why like obj
is not a great file format I mean
there's lots of reasons why but one of
them is it's all just like text and so
it requires a lot of string parsing
which is not the fastest thing to do so
this will take a little bit of time yeah
so here V is vertex which again I would
not call it a Vertex I'd call it a
position or a Vertex position because
this whole thing is a vertex and then we
have a normal uh potentially if we have
that there's actually one more obj there
was this other obj called grass dot obj
which looks like this if I take a look
at it in visual Studios model which is
quite uh fun to look at you can kind of
see I don't know how to how to zoom in
here oh okay I can zoom in but the near
plane is a bit bad is a bit uh okay
there we go the near clipping blade this
must be quite small because if I zoom in
any further it Clips it uh but you can
see kind of the triangles of the grass
blade is actually made out of and then
if we take a look at it uh at the actual
file this one's not very big but it's
got our vertex positions our texture
coordinates are just a single vertex
normal at negative one on the X and then
we have our faces which is basically
going to be used for our index buffer so
yeah that's um that's cool we
triangulate it this probably isn't I
don't know if triangulation is going to
be necessary because so far all of the
meshes we've looked at are already
triangulated like if we look at these
you can see they're all like we only
have three components to a face it's not
like they're quads because if they were
quads we'd see one more here because we
need four vertices to make up a quad but
I guess maybe this is just something
safe to do but either way this will
basically build up our vertex which
contains a position and a normal and
that will be used to create a GPU side
buffer and upload the data to the GPU
and then we Define the attributes all
pretty standard nothing too special
going on here we have a render instance
function which is a little bit fancy so
yeah we are probably using instance
instances and so that will draw
triangles if we just take a look at this
function quickly so we have first zero
and then count is vertices dot size
vertices.size
oh right that's because draw arrays so
the draw arrays part this is how many
vertices we're drawing we're not using
an index buffer at all here and then
instance count is how many instances of
this we want to draw okay cool going
back to main uh grass renderer yeah like
to be honest so far with the code like
there's yeah there's little things I'm
noticing like for sure like for example
unsigned and like you shouldn't use that
use un32t instead uh however like you
know and then obviously none of these
are like initialized they should be
um you're probably initializing stuff
like start time I imagine otherwise oh
yeah and you know of this way of
initializing it as well your code style
in general I would not use this I would
you know drop this down here I would
make sure that my uh curly brackets here
on new lines like this because that's
kind of the convention
don't worry I know you're coming from
java when I I also came from java into C
plus plus and for a while I used to
write code like this as well and I would
like literally almost fight people for
wanting to drop this onto a new line but
then I
started working at EA and kind of
humbled myself a bit and I more or less
adopted their code style uh and the more
kind of common C plus plus one which is
dropping it onto new line so I get where
you're coming from but I would
personally uh make that change it will
make the code appear a lot cleaner and
easier to read because it's just gonna
be less dense basically
um okay so the grass renderer is
probably the biggest kind of thing to
look at here I know I've probably spent
a little bit too much time on the other
things but I just wanted to kind of be
as detailed as I can uh okay so
basically if we look at this
um yeah sure so we create we we get
these kind of like projection Matrix
view Matrix and time uniform buffer
objects they're called uh here but I
don't think they're let's actually take
a look at the shaders because this will
help understand this where are the
shaders okay I want to look at so this
one's called grassverter extra glsl and
then we have grass fragmented yourself
so if we look at the vertex model for a
second
um yeah like projection Matrix view
Matrix and time they're not uniform
buffers uh they're just uniforms so I
don't know if ubo is a good name for
them ssbo so that's like some Shader
storage buffer object I think it's
called Uh that's going to be this buffer
here in other apis we just call them
like buffers or like storage buffers so
I'm not really that familiar with like
the opengl kind of term for this but
this is just basically a storage buffer
of all of our grass positions and then
we set start time to current time
milliseconds that's interesting which
will get the current time I guess time
since Epoch in milliseconds I also
wouldn't probably write it this way I
would just set my start time to like
zero uh so that I get a predictable
start time every time and then every
frame yeah we're taking like a Time step
and increment it by the time step uh
essentially right so that will always
get
basically the current time in
milliseconds or in seconds or however
much I want it but it'll kind of I guess
start at zero and just accumulate
instead of having to do all of this like
stuff every time you want to calculate
the current time you just increment it
by the time step and pass it in and
you're done now we do create the storage
buffer here so we have a Shader storage
buffer
um how big is this guy
bind buffer bind buffer base I forget
about this stupid like there's like some
bind buffer and bind buffer bass like I
don't know I feel like opengl is
sometimes even a bit complicated like I
guess this is I think this code
from memory binds it to this binding
equals zero thing I think that's why the
zero is here to bind this actual this is
just creating like a buffer I guess and
that's
um binding it to that this spot in the
Shader which yeah is a bit weird
um the way that that works okay cool
um still not seeing that buffer get
populated anywhere here but we are looks
like we are actually binding it but we
also have this grass chunks here so
grass chunks okay so grass chunks in
place back and then we have a grass
chunk size here of 0.5 and we create
this kind of grass chunk
class instance here which has a grass
Starcraft stop
and it creates a bounding box for it uh
yeah like I wouldn't initialize a random
device and random engine for each grass
chunk this probably this is probably
something you could definitely optimize
because you're probably creating quite a
lot of these grass chunks right like if
we look at the console it said you
created 40 000 of these so you're in
doing this forty thousand times whereas
like I mean you know this distribution
you sure you can leave leave that in
because this scarcity kind of depends
that defines it but this stuff man like
I would bring it out here and just make
it static like that because that there's
no way that that needs to be initialized
every single time and then over here in
Randa okay right so over here in Randa
you're calling jail buffer data
with that
oh okay
this I don't think is the best idea
so you're gonna eventually draw the
instances here okay I see so you're not
using uh you don't have like a transform
buffer or anything instead what you've
got is this storage buffer of grass
positions which
well there's a lot of stuff going on
there's a lot of stuff going on here in
your vertex Trader
wow okay probably too much yeah there's
like some wind variance rotation
yeah there's a lot of there's quite a
lot of stuff I probably wouldn't do this
much work here in the Shader
um
I would probably maybe expand your grass
positions buffer to have a little bit
more so for example like you have a
rotation that you apply here it looks
like so okay so let's kind of look at
this Shader so first of all we have like
our grass position which we retrieve
from this storage buffer so we have a
bunch of vector grass positions why they
vectors because if you look at like a
plane with all of this grass distributed
obviously we don't care about the height
of the grass it's all at the moment
going to be on this plane and since it's
on this flat plane then we all we only
need an X and A Z position we don't need
a y position hence the vector is what
I'm assuming now this obviously is not
going to work if instead of a flat plane
you actually have like some kind of
terrain going on in that case you
probably need to maybe look at like the
closest Vertex or something or with like
a point within a triangle I guess to see
the X Y and Z so that you can actually
kind of have grass growing from a let me
switch to Green for grass you can have
grass growing from like a specific
height level right so it's not going to
automatically work for any mesh that's
going to be important you should be able
to basically Place grass onto any mesh
right that's a good feature to have and
well necessary if you're doing more than
just a little grass rendering test and
then from there though we generate this
like random floors but the random float
takes in Grass position as this kind of
Co thing right and so if you look at
this math of course this math is going
to be completely deterministic and we
can predict it for a specific
like grass position that we pass in
which means that if you're rendering
that same blade of grass every single
frame it's going to give you the same
result so this isn't going to be like a
random number that changes frame to
frame it's going to be constant per
grass blade ultimately and that's I mean
I assuming that's what we want otherwise
all of this would fall apart right but
what I don't like is that you're using
this
to like generate a random rotation it's
not actually a random rotation basically
what's going to happen is since this
random value will give you the same
value for each like blade of graph for
each unique blade of grass it's going to
basically take one of your Blades of
grass and position it facing a
particular direction right so that
rotation though multiplied with this
position and then also kind of
generating this random number which
isn't like the cheapest thing there's
like a there's like a sign in here and
also to do rotation y like you build up
this this this like three by three
Matrix basically you've written it out
as a four by four Matrix but really it's
just that inner rotation that you care
about so this this this this this and
this can just go away and this whole
kind of row here so actually one one way
to like slightly potentially optimize
this I don't know if this will end up
being much faster because gpus love
their like uh 4x4 kind of thing but uh
if we if we were to write this three by
three Matrix out getting rid of all of
these things the then you could just do
your rotation y you know you're taking
your rotation but instead of making this
position now a VEC four and then getting
x y z you can just get rid of like this
part uh entirely and then this is just
going to be an and all of this and then
this is just going to be like this matte
3 multiplied with this position right so
there's no there's no there's no reason
to make it a mat4 because your trans
your translation the translation section
of your Matrix is just zero anyway and
you're not trying to translate you're
trying to rotate so that's kind of
another optimization that I would make
but again coming back to this I just
don't like the fact that this is all
done inside a Vertex Shader per vertex
like we don't need to generate a random
a random rotation per grass blade we
don't need to do that multiplication and
actually build up this rotation Matrix
for every vertex all of that can be
pre-computed and stored inside some kind
of storage buffer so that you can just
go right because it's all the same it's
all the same for like it's different per
grass blade sure but it's all static
frame to frame it's not like it's
Dynamic right like the the swaying and
all of that that doesn't like the
displacement that you've got here that
does need to be calculated obviously
pervertex potentially per frame right
that makes sense but this stuff I would
just kind of pre-calculate that once
when you generate your grass chunk and
then that's it uh and that will that
will improve performance considerably
the only reason why you maybe wouldn't
do that if is if there were some kind of
memory considerations but I uh I
wouldn't think that that would be much
of a problem if we go back to uh our
grass chunk it also seems like I mean I
need to because you're not using buffer
sub data you're using gel buffer data so
doesn't that allocate memory like
wouldn't that allocate this buffer every
frame basically every time you call
render
because we probably don't want to do
that if the blade number doesn't change
we probably just want to allocate this
once and then use buffer sub data to
potentially stream in Grass positions
per chunk but again like in my in my
world you'd already have the grass
positions pre-calculated in fact they
are pre-calculated because they're here
right I think what's going on here
is he's rendering each chunk one by one
I guess and so since each chunk is
rendered one by one we need to set like
a new set of grass positions per chunk
that we render will be kind of
interesting to run this through
renderdoc potentially is going to run
with my current changes or have I run
the Shader yep I ruin the Shader let's
get rid of that uh let's get rid of his
like 4x4 Matrix we'll just switch to
using our three by three one all right
cool that works so let's go ahead and
run this through render Dock and we'll
see how it works alright so here we are
in Insight because Running Dog crashed
on me twice because I'm using trying to
capture this but here we can kind of
scrub through this and you can start to
see how it's working so wait we are
actually rendering a lot of chunks here
that are barely visible so that's not a
really great lotting system I think well
actually they did mention a lot system
so we might take a look at what those
chunks look like we just can't see them
very well uh maybe that's there is some
hope there although they do look like
just the cross blades I guess uh and
then you can see we kind of go through
these chunks and render them one by one
so this is how it's happening and I'm
assuming that like for a given draw call
like this one over here so this is jail
draw arrays uh instanced and we're
drawing how many are we drawing here
let's take a look so twenties uh 3906
instances so that's kind of I guess how
many instances we have per chunk this is
it being drawn over here and then if we
take a look at
um all of these details here then you
can see we have like this positions
buffer and if we take a look at the
positions buffer it's just filled with
positions uh predictably and let me just
hit configure I don't know why it's yeah
I guess it doesn't know what type it is
but what are these vectors right
so if we just display them as vectors
then you can see the data a lot more
clearly so these are like for that chunk
these are just all of the kind of
two-dimensional x and z positions for
each blade of grass and we have quite a
lot of these we have like what 4 000
almost for that given chunk so that's
kind of the reason why we're like
setting the buffer data every frame like
that I don't know if I would necessarily
do that uh I guess it does make sense to
dynamically set the data like that
that's okay the only thing that I
definitely wouldn't do though is like
reallocate it like that that definitely
does not need to be done if that is
what's happening if we go back to Grass
chunk like jail buffer data like this
should be jail buffer sub data with
whatever your buffer actually is and
then you should do the initial gel
buffer data um in uh in your main class
let me just close this because it's just
lagging so over here in like the grass
renderer when you create this you should
do your GL uh buffer
data right and actually allocate the
memory here it's I think it's safe to
assume that every chunk will have the
same number of grass blades even if it
doesn't you could have a max number of
grass blades and then a uniform to make
sure that you don't read past that and
don't render too many you don't even
need a uniform though because it's just
going to uh you know when you actually
do the instance rendering here you're
rendering like your instance counter
obviously match how many grass plays you
want to render so you're never going to
pass the buffer but the point is you
could generate a buffer with your max a
number of grass blades per chunk and
then just simply stream that data in if
you want every frame like this and
that's fine uh also you're using GL
static draw which uh again if you did
create this not here but here like you
should have so if we just do jail buffer
data over here a number of glass blades
uh is there is it like a maximum we can
have or is it is it just predict is it
is it really it might actually just be
the same for each chunk but let's just
arbitrarily set this to something like I
don't know 4096 right uh we'll set the
data to null pointer and we should set
this to Dynamic draw not static draw
because you are going to be updating at
every frame in fact multiple times per
frame so if we just do that I wonder and
then we come back here change this to
buffer sub data
uh and then we have an offset of zero a
size of this and then that's our grass
positions which what is that that's a
vector pointer
um yeah which is an array basically of
vectors like I wonder if that's going to
make any difference
uh to our performance okay it doesn't
really look like it it's still hovering
around 160 FPS and that's probably
because I'm assuming the the majority of
the actual work here is going to be
spent rendering like all of those
triangles because there's going to be
quite a lot this chunk bounding box is
on Frost and this is like all the math
here to basically check to see if it's
uh inside the camera's view which is
good now the last thing I want to do is
if we look at the fragments Shader let's
have a look at this quickly so cool
we've got our little fog Factor there's
a few different potential equations I
guess we can use maybe we're playing
around with different uh like fog Styles
or fog equations or something but
ultimately we set the frag color to
looks like based on the height of the
blade of grass we determine a color
between these two which is okay probably
wouldn't use a mix for this necessarily
I think I would just Define some kind of
grass color so maybe like you could
Define this as your grass color
and then I would have some kind of like
float light scale and that would be
basically the height because you're kind
of mixing between two vac threes here
per Channel as well kind of which is
like I mean it's going to be the same
per channel it's not going to be a
linear interpolation because height is
going to be the same across all you know
XYZ here but
um you know you could have your little
light scale your grass color and then
your frag color in this case could just
be
like you could just do like grass color
times equals you know light scale
um which for now I've said to hide I'm
assuming that's between zero and one and
then you can just set
your grass color and one like that
let's see what that looks like okay cool
uh I think it probably should be a
little bit darker let me actually go
back to
um the 1000 by 1000 resolution just
because I don't like the chunks uh not
being there and I'll I might actually
Square height just to make that curve be
a little bit like you know darker
basically because the values would blow
yeah that looks kind of cool I think
there is like it shouldn't be completely
black at the bottom especially with this
density maybe if it was denser that
would make sense and the way you could
fix that is just by basically adding
some kind of minimum to this so light
scale this is going to be zero what is
where it's zero but we could either like
clamp that basically so that let's say
it doesn't go below 0.2 and that would
just kind of clamp it out or we could
add to it so that the curve starts a
little bit higher and you can see this
just gets us that kind of Darkness but
it's just not to that extent so there's
there's a few different ways we could do
that that almost seems a little bit too
light though okay cool now the other
thing that I would say this needs is
some kind of variance in the color
because at the moment every single grass
blade is just like the same green I mean
that like it varies based on the the
height of the pixel along the grass
blade but they're all just green and
that's weird we need like a bit of
yellow in there we need just a variance
in color now because you already have
that random being calculated in the
vertex Shader uh and which is fine right
I think what I might do because that's
also based on the individual grass blade
not the vertex so even though we're
doing it per vertex we're actually going
to get the same exact value
for every vertex along a single grass
blade because it's going to be the same
grass position right so for each
instance we're going to get the same
random value because this is really the
seed kind of not really the seed but the
the the number we pass in to try and do
some math and get a different number out
that is seemingly random so what I'm
going to do is just output that random
that's another thing you could use
probably some kind of conventions for
your uh variables here and you could
even like make some kind of like out
struct instead of having to use this
because you are using using version like
430 so you definitely support that that
would just tidy this up a bit but it's
okay you know it's not like it's a big
deal uh so the output random here is
just going to be random
and then if we go back to our fragment
Shader we can use this random now to
randomize like this color to an extensor
for example now random I think is going
to be between zero and one so we have to
keep that in mind but if we like for
example want to add a little bit more
red to make it kind of more yellow we
could drop that a little bit just so we
get some nice Greener kind of grass
blades but then add on random but if we
just leave it at that then it's going to
add on either 0 or up to one which means
obviously this could be as high as 1.2
which is way too high so we need to
multiply this by like what do I want it
to go up to like I guess 0.6 so I'll
make it 0.4 so that this can be now
between 0.2 and 0.6 similarly with the
amount of green I want to drop the
initial green because that is going to
be the not the new kind of lowest
possible value of green and then I'll
add on uh this now 0.4 is probably going
to be too much maybe 0.3 because it'll
go up to 0.8 in that case instead of 0.9
and then with blue like we'll drop that
I guess and then we'll just add on maybe
not an own point to up to 0.2 so let's
take a look at uh this and see if we
have that kind of variance now and there
we go so we have a bit of variance now
now it's not perfect uh you can see that
it's a little bit
um if I kind of zoom in here for a bit
we can see that variance I think a lot a
lot easier it's very like uh
the aliasing is terrible and everything
but especially at that zoom level but um
you can definitely see the distinction
some of them are greener than others we
have a more kind of yellow thing it
looks a little bit cooler I think
because you have that kind of variance I
would probably also make them just in
general go like be more yellow the
higher they get as well so we're kind of
just multiplying it by a light scale but
here you really could mix in your kind
of uh you know height where potentially
like based on height as well
um so if we just do like height times
0.5 plus that like this is probably 0.5
is probably going to be way too much but
this will probably yeah that's just
going to give us yellow town but um and
we could probably lower the randomness
then let's lower the randomness a bit so
0.2 because we've introduced that height
now and yeah this will kind of make it
be a little bit Greener below and then
go up to a little bit more yellow and
then the the floor here I would make
basically the base color I still think
this like density they're definitely too
black because you can see that light can
clearly come in and hit the area here if
they were if they were like very dense
then I would definitely you know make it
darker like this but I just think this
is probably way too dark so I might even
make this like 0.3 or something because
they are so sparse and then you'll kind
of see this a little bit better but the
idea is you kind of want the bass to
match the floor color obviously so they
fade out kind of more towards that but
yeah that's kind of I guess my grass and
some of the things I would change of
course this is one of those things you
can tweak like forever the height of the
grass also I noticed wasn't really uh
you know it was very similar they all
seem to just be like this height you
know it would be nice to see like grass
that is uh well first of all closer
together potentially like grass kind of
uh clumps right but then also maybe some
of them are like this big and then you
have the bigger grass blades but
otherwise they're all kind of uniform
High which also doesn't look great but
those are kind of my suggestions and
some of the things I would change but I
hope you guys enjoyed this code review
if you did please hit the like button
below also let me know like if you have
any other opinions about all the code
we've seen here or about grass rendering
maybe I'll make a video on grass
rendering in Hazel kind of try and make
that an educational thing because I yeah
I've got a lot of a lot of potential
things I could do here as I mentioned if
you want me to review your code then
send it in to channelreview gmail.com
all the details will be in the
description below don't forget to check
out brilliant brilliant.org the Cherno
it honestly is such a great place to
learn math and various other stem topics
I will see you guys next time goodbye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]